les étudiants qui manifestent à l'entrée
de leur établissement
c'est une première dans la longue
histoire de l'esad l'établissement
supérieure d'art et de design de
d'orléans il affiche sur les murs
extérieurs et dans les couloirs les
raisons de ce mouvement dont le fond
rejoint celui lancé en même temps par
les syndicats du personnel
ça fait un moment qu'on est ici et on
remarque effectivement un mal être dans
nos équipes enseignantes
les profs qui font des burnout des profs
qui partent en dépression ça nous vient
à nos oreilles et ça a des répercussions
sur l'organisation pédagogique
l'organisation de nos cours et aussi sur
l'organisation du diplôme pour ceux qui
sont en troisième en troisième année
jacqueline faivre la directrice de
l'esad ne nie pas qu'il puisse y avoir
des problèmes
mais les relativise et je sais pas si un
mal être s'est instaurée au niveau de
l'esad que effectivement certains
enseignants certaines personnes ou
certains certains agents aient pu avoir
effectivement des moments de mallettes
c'est indéniable suis laid ça existe on
est dans une société qui dure et les
chats 2 n'est pas exempte de cela on est
un lieu de mouvement la mobilité on est
un lieu de changement et c'est parfois
difficile à vivre mais ce mal-être les
syndicats du personnel ont fondu tout
autre analyse en relation directe avec
le management de l'école aujourd'hui on
a quand même des professeurs et du
personnel en larmes qui viennent sans
arrêt dans nos bureaux
on n'arrête pas de d'alerté de dire que
là on peut pas laisser ces gens en
souffrance on a des dépressions nahd et
burn out on a carrément des gens
complètement en arrêt depuis des mois et
des mêmes bientôt bientôt presque un an
on peut pas laisser faire les choses les
cgt la cfdt demande donc une véritable
enquête du chsct
le comité d'hygiène et de sécurité mais
la mairie tutelle de l'école la refuse
mettant en place un audit une société
privée